[Music]
hello and welcome to spectator tv i'm
cindy you the spectators broadcast
editor on this week's show
boris johnson is still in a perilous
position the prime minister is being
pressured on three fronts his ethics
advisor has just resigned he's fighting
back against the northern ireland
protocol and the government is trying to
implement a controversial rwanda plan
i'll be joined by politics team james
forsyth and katie balls to discuss it
all
are liberal democracies suffering crises
of leadership around the world the
spectator's deputy editor freddie gray
argues so in this week's cover article
and he'll be joining us
we'll then talk about one of those
democracies france macron may be one of
the liberal leaders in the strongest
position for now but he's fending off a
challenge from the left i'll be joined
by john rick mcarthur president of
harpers magazine and french journalist
and elizabeth mootee
we'll also be taking a look at the
supposed roy's royce of the british
civil service is it time to break up the
treasury economists howard davis and
jared lyons will join me
and finally has artificial intelligence
already become sentient google engineers
have released a conversation they had
with an ai which is um somewhat
disturbing the spectator sam leath and
the philosopher julian sabolescu will
join the show
before we get going why not subscribe to
the spectator you can get 12 weeks off
the spectator in print and online for
just 12 pounds i will send you a copy of
douglas murray's new book the war on the
west absolutely free subscribe today at
spectator dot co dot uk forward slash
book
and why not subscribe to our youtube
channel too click the red subscribe
button at the bottom of the video and
tap the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
boris johnson is desperately trying to
regain control of the political agenda
after a rocky few weeks the pm's ethics
advisor has just resigned the government
has said that it will unilaterally
abandon some parts of the northern
ireland protocol and it's trying to keep
alive its rwanda deportation plan for
refugees it's not an easy week but are
some of these fights actually good for
the government to explain i'm joined by
katie balls and james forsyth
james let's start with the resignation
of lord geit the government's ethics
advisors the second that boris johnson
has had um so far
at the moment of recording we still
don't know what the full um resignation
letter is saying because the government
is refusing to publish it so do we know
what was the last straw for lord god
so we know that the resolution letter
will be published later on today i think
people will be reading that of great
interest and street put out this very
curious statement last night saying that
he had been asked to advise on a
commercially sensitive matter in the
national interest
and i i mean that left people very
puzzled i think what is quite clear is
that law guide has been frustrated for
some time uh first of all there was uh
he was put in charge of looking into
this whole issue of the redecoration of
a downing street flat and then once the
guy should conclude his inquiry further
messages came to light that law guy then
had to kind of respond to him that put
him in an extremely awkward position we
also know from the uh annual update from
him that he was extremely irritated that
the prime minister hadn't explained how
he didn't think that getting a fixed
penalty notice uh was uh
why he thought that was that was
consistent with his obligations on the
ministerial code to uphold the law
and then there was an extremely
difficult uh time in front of a
parliamentary select committee this week
for a little guide
and you know he would he would he would
only be human if he decided that he had
enough and i mean the problem for boris
johnson is he's now lost two ethics
advisors uh lord gait was quite clear
but the changes to the role
were at a low end of ambition and i
think it is very hard to see how boris
johnson's gonna persuade anyone to do
this job
unless they are given the power to
initiate investigations of their own
accord
i mean katie after last week's
no-confidence vote it does seem like
boris johnson had temporarily stabilized
uh the
the the situation with his own position
do you think this is going to move the
dial again
well i think in a way this has come at
an okay time for boris johnson i think
had it been during the day on monday
last week ahead of the confidence vote
it would have been much worse timing and
would have added to you know concerns of
those mps who were wavering as to which
way to go but i think it's clearly not
good news for the prime minister it's
clearly difficult for the reasons that
james has outlined and i think it just
does play into that anxiety amongst some
tory mps who are starting to think that
they're finding it harder and harder to
defend the prime minister's behavior and
i think to lose the second ethics
advisor um clearly feeds into it
james let's take a look at some of the
other things on the government's agenda
this week you've written your political
column for the magazine about the row
with the eu over the northern ireland
protocol can you update viewers on the
situation there because you say that it
doesn't show the eu or the uk in a good
light
so yeah so the uk has published its
legislation to kind of rewrite the
protocol um this legislation is is broad
uh and i and i think the and it is the
uk is saying this is not a breach of
international law but i justify it by
this thing called adoption of necessity
now i mean there are there are two
problems with this as a legal position
one is that the uk did sign the protocol
document itself and you're not allowed
to use the doctrine of necessity if your
your own actions have got you to that
place and the second problem is but the
protocol contains its own safeguard
mechanism you know article 16 safety
valve
and i think people question why the uk
is moving to unilateral legislation
despite not having invoked article 16
and tried to resolve the problems that
way
i think the reason it reflects badly on
the eu is but i mean the eu
is being inflexible on the protocol
and i think it is quite clear it's quite
hard to say that the protocol
and the good friday agreement are
sitting easily when all three strands of
a good friday agreement are in such
difficulty
and i think the other problem is you
know the number of people who think that
the protocol needs to change this goes
you know tony blair and peter manelson
both think they need to be changed to
the protocol even if they decry the uk's
government's tactics
and so i think that you know i think
what is needed is it it is a more
reasonable pragmatic approach from both
sides but the problem is that trust is
in very short supply which makes things
hard and i also think that this is a
real world consequence of the fact that
boris johnson faced that confidence vote
last week and only narrowly survived it
you know you talk to people on the eu
side and a lot of people on the eu side
take the view what's the point of
negotiating with someone who might not
be prime minister in a year's time
if you were prepared to make concessions
wouldn't it be better to wait until as a
new prime minister and use that as like
a moment to reset the uk eu relationship
and katie then there's rwanda do you
think the government could really
withdraw from the european court of
human rights which is what
fundamentally blocked uh some of the
refugees from taking off to kigali
earlier this week or is this all what
you've just talked about on the show
before as being a wedge issue that
actually number 10 kind of welcomes so i
think we've seen this week that
ministers clearly want to keep the
option on the table of leaving the echr
you can see that in comments made by the
prime minister as well as other
ministers including the attorney general
suarez braverman um but in terms of the
likelihood i think the first instinct is
to look at other options um so for
example looking at whether you can
appeal the points that led the judges
and strasbourg to make that decision in
terms of grounding that flight and then
also could you have a british bill of
rights which would add a new framework
alongside it that would give big more
weight to british judgments when they
when they are considered um in terms of
the general uh
direction this policy is going in i
think that you look at the drama this
week in terms of the first flight not
going and i don't think this is seen as
a disaster in government now it clearly
creates problems that they have to find
answers to but just look for example
that how as a prime minister he brought
up the rwanda policy
at prime minister's questions this week
usually if you weren't able to action
your policy the next day you would not
be trying to draw attention to it but
boris johnson and number 10 think that
they can actually
attack labour on this issue and paint
labor as one of the many
you know parties establishment figures
trying to fraud their plans plans that
they think are very popular with their
voters particularly those who
they won in the 2019 election in the red
wall that said as much as they are
leaning into this fight whether it's
prince charles labor bishops
i think there are limits in the sense
that at some point in the coming months
they are going to have to be able to get
some of those flags to actually take off
if they are to show that this policy has
a level of government competence
katie and james thanks very much and for
you at home if you'd like to hear more
political analysis from kt and james
obviously pick up the magazine but also
you can tune into our coffeehouse shots
podcast which is a daily politics
podcast so you can get that wherever you
listen from
from the uk to the us germany to italy
it seems that liberal democratic leaders
are in trouble in this week's cover
article freddie gray traces the problem
to pre-inflation pre-pandemic a deeper
rot within the system he joins me now
freddie can you start by telling us what
is happening in democracies around the
world
well i don't think uh democracy is
looking particularly healthy around the
world uh i think one of the big themes
one of the big media themes
of the 21st century has been that we are
having a rise of the strong man
in global politics and that's certainly
true if you look at countries like
china russia turkey
brazil the philippines hungary
uh however i think if you look at sort
of supposedly more advanced democracies
uh
they are all and particularly in 2022
and at this stage in 2022
they are looking uh
in grave peril leaderships are in crisis
uh
you see
all over the world you see it in sweden
you see it in spain you see it in the
netherlands
in britain in america
uh leaderships are being challenged not
just by the electorates but by the
political systems themselves so i think
there is a crisis in in democratic or
what you might call liberal democratic
leadership and i think it's pretty
severe
i mean in particular one of the things
that you picked up on which i hadn't
heard before was that the fact that
biden might be impeached um just briefly
on that because it is a bit of a
digression but why would he be impeached
is that for anything specific that he's
done or just a revenge from the
republicans well i think there's a lot
of resentment uh about the trump
impeachments in the republican party i
mean some of the republican party quite
like the fact that trump was impeached
but there's a general sense that the
democrats tried to use all the
institutions of governments and every
device that they could
to stymie trump's presidency and so
therefore if we look ahead to the
november midterms where as widely
everybody expects
the uh republicans are going to win the
majority in house congress probably the
senate too
will they try and pursue an impeachment
as an act of revenge not because they're
actually remove biden i don't think
there's any real chance of that unless
the democrats decide to join in too
because they need a super majority of
two-thirds majority to remove biden
will they join it in because it's just a
thing that is going to happen in
american democracy in the future people
call it impeachment you know it it
becomes a mechanism that people use to
undermine a leader
is to impeach them
and impeachment was not meant to be
something that was regularly deployed
but the problem is it's now looking as
it will be regularly deployed as a
as a way of undermining a leader
and if impeachment is this mechanism
then what do you think the root cause of
this kind of um shared symptom of things
happening across democracies eyes i mean
you mentioned inflation for example is
it because of that or is it because of
the pandemic why do you think that these
countries are having these problems i
think it's a series of crises going back
uh to the
the war on terror which undermined uh
faith that the the elites political
elites knew what they were doing that
was then compounded by the financial
crisis of 2008 and now we move on we go
through that got worse populism rose
in the decades that followed and then we
get into the covid which was obviously a
huge accelerator of trends
and now we have inflation on top of that
which is the consequence of covid and
all these things serve to undermine
liberal democracy as as it was once
revered
the problem for a lot of democracies is
that the alternatives the democratic
alternatives are equally
unpalatable and so what you have is a
situation which as a as i say in the
piece is what michael did called turbo
paralysis where democracies are flitting
between
uh insurgents sort of radical populist
people who who
threaten to break the rules break the
institutions and
uh
liberal parties that threaten to bring
us back to normal
neither of which are actually solving
any problems we're just sort of stuck in
a loop
i i have to say i'm a slightly more
optimistic on this one than you already
which you might be i thought you would
be
just that when you were for example
talking about the pandemic in your piece
you know you mentioned that china was
initially held up as an example i think
it's pretty clear now that the chinese
model is not really working and
you and i are talking in this office
that well we don't have to wear masks we
don't have to do testing we haven't been
locked down since and god knows how long
covered feels like a past memory but
shanghai is still going into lockdown
and repeatedly so i don't know maybe i
am a bit more optimistic on this one
than you are
well i think certainly china's zero
lockdown uh
obsession is threatening the global
economy however you do have to
face the fact that we've we've had
two years of lockdowns which have
severely crippled
economies they severely crippled
liberties
in the western world and at first what
was very weird is how
eagerly countries that have
traditionally been obsessed with
freedoms
uh rejected them and we're very eager to
jump them in order to deal with this
public health problem we're now dealing
with a situation where there are there's
lingering resentment and kind of in
chaotic
anger towards the countries and the
leaders that did it and that's what
we're dealing with at the moment is
electorates even if they don't express
it in polls are rejecting the the public
figures that introduce these lockdowns
so is there something distinctly
democratic about the problem then
because one thing that you point out in
your piece is that for example if you
were to tackle inflation the methods
would be unpopular and they would be
painful and the electorate simply
wouldn't have it i guess undemocratic
countries don't have to worry about that
as much
well i think they actually do uh i think
that's why we're trapped is is that
everybody knows that
liberal democratic systems are not
dealing with inflation very well however
if you look to authoritarian countries
they're even worse at dealing with
inflation you know erdogan is the best
example inflation in turkey is at 75
some people say more
centralized often very highly corrupt
governments
don't deal inflation don't deal with
inflation very well
uh and so then we revert back to
liberalism but we're not happy with that
because liberalism isn't tackling
inflation either so
a rock and a hard place i think liberal
democracies are caught in between the
two
absolutely and how much do you think
this is because of a lack of talent at
the top um because you write about this
fear of something worse factor
yes well if you look at if you look at
most elections now in uh advanced
democracies they aren't decided by who
who people like
uh
they're decided by who people despise
and that's always been true in democracy
to a certain extent but i think it's got
worse recently
and that is a consequence of the fact
there aren't tremendously talented
people going to politics i mean a thing
that's often talked about is why in
america a country of 300 billion people
you don't have a higher caliber of
candidate where you've got trump versus
biden or trump versus hillary or any of
the democratic or any of the republican
nominees who don't seem that high
caliber why is that happening and it's
similar in britain too i mean boris
johnson survived by the skin of his
teeth last week
uh principally i think for the reason
that there is no
uh
viable alternative to for the leadership
well freddie great thank you so much for
that optimistic note and thank you for
joining spectator tv glad to be cheery
now let's take a closer look at one of
those countries though micron secured a
second term in the elysee earlier this
year he's now fending off a challenge in
the parliamentary elections from the
left led by the 70 year old jean-luc
john rick macarthur president of
harper's magazine is in paris this week
and writes about it in the issue he
joins me now together with french
journalist and elizabeth mootee
thank you for joining us today on
spectator tv rick and and elizabeth
um and elizabeth just to start with
could you explain the parliamentary
elections going on in france at the
moment how do they work because we've
just had the presidentials it feels like
this is something that's relatively
recent and that's when about 20 years
ago we changed from a seven year a
mandate seven years um to a five-year
term and and this was decided by
jackshirak who hadn't quite realized
because he already had a first seven
year term uh that it would change many
things in in in french also the french
political time
and until then the the general election
the legislative election were decoupled
from the presidential election but now
it has become in effect uh a
confirmation of what people voted for
president uh a month or two afterwards
and it's just something in which people
who already have got a bit of election
fatigue that told to vote twice again
because we always have two rounds in
order to having given power to a
president decide whether we want him to
have a difficult time of it and have a
fractious national assembly uh that
would be opposed to what he thinks or
whether he will have the means to to
govern all together with parliament
squarely behind him and so emmanuel
macron is watching the result uh in sort
of you know some worry because if he
doesn't have parliament with him then
it's going to not be not impossible to
govern it has existed before a president
one color and a parliament of the other
one meteorologist through that very well
jacques hack went through that not
liking it
it can be done but it's not it's not
half as easy
and rick you've been spending some time
with potential challenges to macron this
coalition of parties on the left called
noops can you tell us about it
well it's hard to describe because it's
it's so hastily put together i call it
in my piece i call it ungainly
because you have
a pretty
s serious left winger jean-luc
allied with some very mainstream
socialists uh
and and even more mainstream in some
respects greens and
communists i don't understand their
position but
the socialists are
the descendants of what
hard leftists refer to as the caviar
left soft leftists
uh ready to make a deal with anybody
including people with a lot of money
and um uh so they're in they're in bad
odor right now they're discredited
but in order to have any kind of a
chance in this uh
legislative election
mental shell had to create out of
nothing really a coalition
a left coalition
and whatever you think of mel shaw as a
person or as a politician
you have to give him credit for having
put this thing together in about 10
minutes because they don't like him i
mean the leaders of the two of the
greens and the socialists really just
actually dislike him
and the mainstream what we would think
of as a center-left press
lamonde
hates him
so um it's kind of extraordinary that
they were able to put this thing
together
now at the same time
you need to know that there's a big
fissure on the left about
europe and the probably the biggest
compromise i think that melanchol had to
make in order to put this coalition
together was to soften his position on
europe because previously he's been a
very euroskeptic
even openly
anti-german uh uh
politician
but in order to get the socialists and
the greens on he can't go around
uh calling for a referendum on the euro
or or calling for disobedience which is
what he used to do we'll just disobey
we'll disobey the european union
regulations and laws uh
on other things like
lowering the retirement age to 60 i
don't think he hadn't had any trouble
with that and what i noticed at the at
the 14th allende small
noops party
was that you
the candidate was most remarkable and
you can't generalize necessarily but the
the the candidate for the 10th district
um uh
uh rodrigo arenas
uh
was a communist he's a former communist
turned green
and he's very very environmentally
conscious and you don't normally
associate communists or even
ex-communists with the environmental
movement so
uh
mel shone is able to harness some of
this enthusiasm and he's become
[Music]
opportunistically i think a big
environmentalist he's now turned
anti-nuclear or he turned anti-nuclear a
while ago
but it's a it's an acrobatic
uh political trick which is really quite
impressive again we can get into his
specific personality and
and history if you want
and elizabeth do you think it has been
impressive because on paper you know as
rick writes about
noops has won you know by a small margin
but it did win the first round of the
parliamentary elections the sunday
passed
well yes but it won
with a little you know somewhere around
26 of the vote which is uh in the last
election in 2017 the left had 37 or 38
of the vote so it is a victory in an
atomized landscape um the question is
are there people do they have a reserve
of votes uh for for for the second round
uh it's it's it's what is what is really
an achievement and i totally agree uh on
this with rick is that uh a minor shaw
who is 70 who has an almost 40-year
career as a politician on the left who's
a wily old bird
managed to
you know basically bully together people
who hate one another and he got them
together because he said this is better
than being out of the race again and
there's a memory in the last two
presidential elections where it was a
race between the right and the extreme
right or the central right and the
extreme right and um a great deal of the
the left including some social democrats
definitely feel that uh there's
something deeply flawed in a system that
allows that so uh he said you know are
you for defeated for victory which makes
it easy to answer and he got he coupled
them together it's very interesting that
if you look at paris for instance you've
got the current mayor and hidalgo who
now is campaigning for a news candidate
uh actually she's campaigning not far
from from arenas constituency and but
bertrand
the previous socialist mayor of paris is
campaigning for a macronist in a
different constituency and that i think
illustrates very well the sort of the
state of mind in which they are in terms
of what is this going to work out but
certainly what the left achieved and
that is that's me not sure the momentum
he knew perfectly well he'd scored
extremely well something like 22 percent
in the in the first round of the
presidential election he came third but
really by a whisker and he realized that
there was a momentum even though half
the people who voted for him were not
necessarily his natural voters and
though he harnessed that immediately so
that people wouldn't sort of turn back
and and uh
this is how he rushed that through and
you have to admire this it's really a
sense of what momentum is
um well what does all of this mean for
success
i was just going to add and i'm not
disagreeing with that i'm just i'm just
adding
uh
to to what she's saying the the feeling
i have
that
he's trying to repeat something uh
his great political hero is francois
which is by the way why i cannot believe
any that that he's a le he's a radical
left winger yeah i don't think anything
authentically left
but but but
was is the great as i say in the piece
the great chameleon of maybe the
all-time great chameleon of french
politics having
famously maybe infamously
been a minister in the vichy government
during the war and winding up the first
socialist president in the fifth
republican in the republic and then
turning right turning kind of right more
right wing in his later years so
um i think mello showed no show admires
me tehan's incredible flexibility and
tactical brilliance
and he's trying to pull off a something
like a mitel
uh miracle now we can
when you say what does this all mean
analizabet knows much better than i do i
think the odds of nukes
winning an absolute majority are
virtually nil
all they can do is deny
uh
the matlonis ensemble a
an absolute majority
but that raises the interesting question
and it's already being played out in the
way
both parties are positioning themselves
against the national front i still call
them the national front
marine le pen's
party
because
imagine a situation where macron needs
the national front to form a majority
will will will he actually do it or will
he uh agree to let melonshone be a prime
minister i can't believe he would allow
donald trump to become prime minister
under any circumstances
and elizabeth this is under the
assumption that the macronese do not
have an outright majority come sunday
i think even the macronesis haven't got
a full majority they've got plenty of
other parties to to you know
get people from
and so i think it's less worrisome that
it sells the no way when mccoy himself
with mahindra pen that is not going to
happen it is even uh it's even possible
that she wouldn't agree either because
um
she has spent her entire life uh
blasting what she called umps which was
the initials of the
right wing and left-wing potters before
and essentially saying it's the same
thing you know the mainstream socialists
and the mainstream right-wingers are
exactly the same and that would be an
illustration so that doesn't work but
and so you still have a republican party
the party
there are people who are perfectly
macron compatible within the republican
party i should say that about two-thirds
of the republican party are
macro-compatible and one-third would be
compatible with the right-wing alliance
but not with mahindra
uh so he he will find people he will
find some socialists as well because
there are socialists uh who are not the
candidate in in in the noobs alliance
and who already are outraged at the idea
that they've joined someone who is
essentially somebody who supported putin
uh vocally and and who's anti-nuclear so
um that's many things in which uh in
which i think uh there's there will
there will not be a problem of macmillan
having to find an alliance with amino
shaw and i'm with rick in saying that
there's almost no chance right now as it
stands and within the front with the
french system which is a
first-past-the-post in two rounds uh
that they will have a majority
so rick why do you think noobs has
resonated with voters so far
well
all i can tell you is what uh
rodrigo arenas told me and he said
he's that he's the co-president of the
sort of the national parents association
school parents association
and he started out in sen sandui which
is a working-class suburb as the local
parent uh
or parents association leader or
president and he's got four kids i mean
he's got four school-age kids and he is
really angry about the school system and
so are a lot of people a lot of
motivated parents
the schools are understaffed overcrowded
uh
it's a rhetoric to some extent a
rhetorical trick but it's got some uh
force in it when rodrigo says that uh
public schools in and we mean uh state
schools for you british thank you
state schools
uh are not really free because the
government pays the salaries of private
school teachers
which comes from everybody's pocket
and
more troubling troublesome
more troublingly the
when a teacher quits especially in an
overcrowded classroom it's very hard to
find a replacement and if you're up
against it and your kid is trying to
pass the buck the baccalaureate exam
you've got to hire a private tutor to
get them through
so these are the sort of things that
great with people they're furious
they're also furious with with lockdown
uh they're probably also furious at the
teachers unions but they're generally
very angry about the education system
and uh
uh arenas thinks he's that a lot of that
he's tapping into this
uh
in fact he seems more like i said in the
piece he seems more upset about the
state of the the condition of the
schools than about global warming right
so that's for environmental issues yeah
so that chameleon act is only going to
go some way and elizabeth how what was
the best case scenario for mel and sean
from here then because he's tried for
the presidency three times now and he's
70 as you say
is this the final political gambit for
him
you know say look at bernie sanders i
mean you know he can he can go on for a
bit and i'm certain she he wants to go
on for a bit i'd like to go back to what
the um uh uh the uh iranis were said the
noobs candidate for the 14th house is
small because every french arab is angry
at the schools the right is as angry at
the school as the left is as angry at
the schools lots of people who vote on
the right are just like british voters
and not especially rich and they don't
like all the extra costs not not
necessarily tutors they don't so much
thinking in terms of that but even sort
of you know going to class is not free
but i would say one thing about private
schools in france the french private
school system is a bit special in that
90 of private schools have a contract
with a french state they follow the
french national curriculum and in
exchange they are subsidized because
they scholarize children that the state
has a duty to scholarize anyway as long
as the teachers are appointed by the
state the curriculum is the state
curriculum the state makes it very
possible for these children to attend
school for something that is one tenth
possibly of of british school fees so
you can realize the interest and you've
got small you know a small minority of
schools which are not contractual as
they are it's called in french and and
those are not do not get for the state
subsidies mitigate tried to abolish uh
the uh uh the the private say the school
system and he had two million people in
the streets
uh in 1984 and he decided that you know
discretion was the best part of banner
on this one but it's a perfectly valid
and i would say the best way to work for
politics on either whichever side you
are to be on grassroots side to to to
tackle schools because french school
levels vengeful system was at the height
at the top of the piece of system for
years and the rankings of primary
schools for years and now we've
fallen down to the bottom in two or
three years and that was just
essentially sort of you know facts
catching up with the the uh uh the ideas
the frequency of notions that the french
key system was excellent teachers are
badly paid they're badly treated the
whole system is a very cumbersome public
system it's a state system every single
teacher depends for the ministry and the
the ethos of the entire system has been
never to support teachers when they have
problems uh whether they are the
problems like you know
that end up with samuel petty being
beheaded but all sorts of problems
there's a kind of cowardice that runs in
the french civil service and it doesn't
serve the children certainly doesn't
serve the teachers they now are taking
for
teachers in school exams uh people who
would not be passed in in normal classes
at university they admit because they
need bodies to teach the kids they take
people who have you know the equivalent
of of a
a third or worse in in in their exams
it's been
written about all over the french press
on the left on the right there's a
strange agreement on this on both sides
it's um and it's something that's
worrisome because uh the french natural
school system was supposed to be very
good it's not well the other thing i was
going to add was uranus by the way would
say that even the modest
fees charged by private and parochial
schools catholic schools are too
expensive for a lot of ordinary french
people but anyway uh
so again it's it's not it's stacked it's
stacked against the
ordinary folks but he's also talking he
talked a lot about the widening gap
between rich and poor it's not as bad as
it is in the united kingdom or in the
united states
france still looks to me very
egalitarian by comparison with the
united states but if you're french
you can't help but notice what's what's
happening and mccall is he's a former
former investment banker i mean he's a
he's to some extent a trickle-down guy
thinks if you throw a lot of money at uh
at the top it'll come down and all boats
will rise and he's a free trader you
know his
uh uh he's you know he's for he's a
liberal in the french sense
uh
i don't know i don't know how people how
how that plays out in a working class
neighborhood
but
there was a book that was a bestseller
what was it three years ago on this
event by the communist uh deputy the
journalist
who
the france you don't know
uh about
it was written as a letter to my home
about how he had just ignored and didn't
care about the ordinary people and it uh
it came out almost as the jiren appeared
didn't it on the scene i've forgotten
the timing
it was
timing yeah so there is a scent there is
a feeling of general
social alienation uh and the feeling
that the rich are are getting off easy
and everybody else is getting the shaft
i i would say one thing which is that
medium has spent the most money public
money in the past three years of any
president of the fifth republic that the
french state uh part of i mean the the
french state sort of spends
57
57
of the french um uh of the french but uh
sorry the budget of the state is 57
percent of of gdp whether it's it's
directly the state or things working for
the state um so
meteor is a big spender
[Music]
at the time he has thrown many at people
he's thrown it in a very strange way
essentially if they shouted loud enough
he threw money at them but it's not this
is not a country that is lean and mean
we've got we've got our fresh debt has
gone as something like 110
now gdp as i said we are probably the
country in western europe that spends
the most uh public spending is the
highest french taxes are also very high
uh so he he is that he's managed to sort
of not please anyone what happens has
happened in france to be fair to mccall
that was before he became president uh
the social mobility has come to a
standstill and macron is the image of
the people who benefited from this
social mobility that or whatever
system in which you have to go through a
very specific way of schooling a special
special schools special universities
they are free sometimes they even pay
you like
uh uh
who go there because they're supposed to
work for the state afterwards and if you
don't go through that hallowed system
which is reserved to a small minority
for instance if you go into french
universities and those include sovereign
you do not get the best jobs it's very
difficult and other things that make it
very difficult it's something that's
been explained by the geographer
christoph guillory in the past 15 years
is if you live in la in paris or in
large big cities in france like
marseille or bordeaux
or not you can you do you can manage to
get onto the system in good schools but
if you want to work in paris you can't
afford the rents if you want to go and
study in a good university half the time
it's too difficult for you it's stacked
against you uh in just after the war you
know that among the great khan zika in
france you have ecole polytechnique
which is much more than an engineering
school it also forms the elites of
france about 30 percent of the students
at polytechnic came from the working
class today it's under eight percent and
it's true of all the quanzicol and no
sort of you know uh showy program of
getting 30 people from the bergeo into
some sport has ever changed that so the
real problem is social mobility
and i just tell you my my french cousins
uh they put their kids in catholic
school
i mean if you can
you you put your kid in a catholic
school just to get go to a school with a
smaller class size that's all yeah it's
a big problem well big big problem rick
and elizabeth i'm gonna have to leave it
there but that's so fascinating to hear
about thank you so much for joining
spectator tv
next inflation is at a 40-year high we
have a spiraling cost of living crisis
at the same time as debt going up is a
treasury doing its job howard davis
wants a special advisor to chancellor
nigel lawson and then deputy governor of
the bank of england has written a new
book charting the course of perhaps the
most important government department the
treasury he says needs more staff if
it's to work better to discuss howard
joins the show now alongside gerald
lyons chief economic strategist at
netwealth
howard to start with tell us about your
new book and what you're trying to do in
it
well 15 or 20 years ago i did a book
called the chancellor's tales where i
got all the then
living chancellors from dennis healey
through to ken clark to come and talk at
the london school of economics actually
about their experiences running the
treasury and that created quite a bit of
interest and it was a jolly good source
book i think for a lot of people
and i then thought in the lockdown well
you know it's been now almost 25 years
since bank of england independence
treasury must have changed a lot
would the current chancellors be
prepared to talk about how it's changed
and they all were and were quite
interested in being interviewed so it
wasn't lectures this time it was
interviews and also quite a lot of the
permanent secretaries and other
officials some anonymously some
some not were prepared to talk through
so what it is is a description of the
last 25 years and the way in which the
treasury has been involved in the key
decisions whether it's scottish
independence the brexit referendum or
the changes to financial
regulation
and all that so i've tried to sort of
allow the treasury if you like to tell
its own story as to how it did what it
did and why it did what it did so it's
not a polemic with a particular
argument but of course i do pick up a
number of issues along the way and i'm
opinionated enough to have some views on
some of them but but basically it's
letting the treasury tell its own story
and what do you think that story of the
last 20-25 years is do you think it has
done well overall
well um the record the economic record
was pretty good up to the financial
crisis
of
2008 so the first sort of decade or so
was actually
quite good
um but the financial crisis has created
unfortunately a change in trend on uh
productivity
and we've still not recovered the same
trajectory of productivity increases
that we had
before 2008
and
more recently you know investment's been
pretty weak and that's been particularly
weak since the brexit referendum
and um so it's a game of two halves
really i think you'd have to say pretty
good
up to the financial crisis
and pretty mixed thereafter i mean the
british economic performance has not
been
radically different from
the performance of say france which is
probably the most directly comparable
country so not very different but not
better which it was between 97 and 2008
right and jared what do you think about
that record because in the past you have
written in support of this idea of
breaking up the treasury into two
different departments
well certainly i think 2008 was the
turning point and the trend rate of
growth before 2008 meant that the uk
economy in real terms doubled probably
every 32 years now the trend rate of
growth means that the uk economy takes
60 years to double yeah expectations are
still as high as they were before 2008
so that really creates a problem but in
in answer to your question about
breaking up the treasury yeah
back in the late 60s harold wilson when
prime minister uh made a comment that
you can be in office but not in power
the treasury is in power he then tried
to address that and the root cause of
his worry has been a worry that i think
has persisted since that the treasury
combines
offices that in other countries are
separate
management of the public finances and
management of the economy and from the
outside and hence it's good to have a
such an interesting book by howard as an
insider so to speak from the outside it
often seems that the control of the
budget supersedes the need to sort of
manage the economy hence i tend to feel
that the treasury should be sort of
split up and indeed when gordon brown
was there as chancellor he managed to
make the treasury a super ministry
tentacles everywhere so that by the time
it was osborne and
cameron osborne was able to push his
austerity mandate even though other
departments were against it they weren't
powerful enough to oppose the treasury
so i think there is an argument to say
there are good things that are done
within the treasury but maybe in terms
of 21st century is it fit for purpose
and should it be split into at least two
different departments howard would you
think
um well curiously enough
gerald when i began to write the book i
thought that's where i would come out
because
you're right most other comparable
countries do have a ministry of economy
taking a more strategic view in the
ministry of finance doing the candle end
stuff
in the end i changed my mind and i
changed my mind following an interesting
conversation with gus o'donnell you know
he was permanent secretary and then
cabinet secretary and he said to me have
you thought where all the ideas for
splitting up the treasury have come from
and there was of course harold wilson's
then under blair there was project teddy
bear weirdly which is uh done by john
burt which aimed to split the treasury
um gordon once he'd left the treasury
wanted to cut it down to size theresa
may wanted to
split it up
and indeed more recently
boris johnson has flirted with the idea
dominic cummings says you know that was
one of their big plans was to split the
treasure and gus said what you know have
you thought about why it is that all
these plans come from next door come
from 10 downing street and that's
because
they are it's the only rival center of
power and since the british
non-constitution
tends towards elective dictatorship of a
prime minister with a working majority
that
the idea of a center of power that's
rival to number 10 is actually quite a
sensible one from a british constitution
point of view and if you divided the
treasury into just a spending control
department and an economic department
you would undoubtedly reduce that rival
center of power so i in the end
concluded that as a kind of
counterbalance to the
inc what can be the excessive power of
number 10 downing street that the
treasury is pretty good as it is so i'm
afraid in the end jared although i i
understand the points you're you're
making and in the end i came out the
other way
it is interesting though in terms of if
one was to judge the output of the
treasury um and i think you alluded to
earlier in terms of post 2008 the
disappointing growth performance of the
uk plus now a whole host of big projects
we're trying to address in terms of
leveling up big issues such as net zero
does make one wonder whether if it's not
the treasury that needs to be split up
is there a way of wait making things
work better across whitehall with the
treasury therefore either in its current
format or maybe in my view in the new
format so that we actually have better
outputs
but how did you feel
um the different people over the 25
years would have approached that that
they would feel the treasury could it be
more effective even if it remained in
its current format
i think there is a problem in that
the treasury's relations and this i
think i hope does come out the book
the treasury's relations with
particularly with the business
department which of course has gone
through it changes its name every year
or so but what is you know what is the
business department uh under whatever
title it happens to be under that the
treasury is always deeply suspicious of
them and always thinks that the business
department is really just coming along
and wanting to bail out lame ducks and
you know etc
uh and i was in that part of the
treasury for a while myself and
certainly that was our view and i think
that's the dysfunctional bit
that the treasury is deeply reluctant to
envisage anything that you might call an
industrial strategy
um and anytime the business department
tries to sort of get consensus around
some areas that we might support and
back you know the treasury's is is runs
a mile from it and and prevents it from
being effective i think to me that's the
crucial relationship that doesn't work
not so much the division between
spending and uh and the economic
department
well jared you've written recently about
the group thing that happens at the
treasury and at the bank of england do
you think what howard has said is a
symptom of that group think this you
know too many similar people probably or
privately educated young men um
not really challenging enough the way
things are done in the past
well absolutely i i think this is
probably more apparent actually at the
bank of england
even though we have independence of the
bank of england the reality seems to be
that it's an offshoot of the treasury
the mandarins recommend to the
chancellor who should be proposed as
governor
the mandarins from the treasury are in
charge of every
appointment for any vice
governor or deputy governor and in
charge of the appointments for all the
senior people in terms of the committees
so the treasury tends to exert its
influence over the bank it's quite
remarkable last year the lack of
disagreement at a time of complexity in
the domestic as well as the global
economy the issue in terms of the
treasury that i've heard explained to me
is that too often it's those people who
are good at keeping the budget under
control who managed to rise to the top
as opposed to those with good ideas but
certainly one interesting thing i found
was back in
2016 i was invited to be on the panel at
the treasury and funnily enough it was
to celebrate or commemorate shall we say
the 40th anniversary of the bailout from
the imf and they had with even i think
it was the person from the imf there
lord owen lordo don who and myself on
the panel and the interesting thing was
to compare in their mind 76 to 2016 and
howard in his book talks about the
brexit situation but the feeling at that
panel session back in
back at the treasure in december 2016
was the documents that came out in 1976
were real ones of substance and indeed
dennis haley's public expenditure white
paper i remember actually explicitly
being mentioned whereas it was felt that
the documents by 2016 were too
politically influenced too much spin and
maybe coming back to your questions in
the is that sort of group thing that not
only groupthink that not only permeates
between the treasury and the bank but
maybe that's very evident at the top of
the treasury in terms of how they
interact with their political masters at
particular times
and just before i let you both go i also
want to get your thoughts on the current
economic situation so obviously how do
you write that since 2008 treasury has
had a mixed record well in the last few
years the pandemic has been a very
difficult time and some would point to
the bank of england at least and
possibly also the treasury that's not
really foreseen the kind of economic
quagmire we're in at the moment um
do you think it kind of took its eye off
the ball i mean maybe jared you want to
go first
well certainly we face two immediate
problems an inflation problem and an
inevitable economic slowdown although
the extent of that slowdown remains to
be seen against that backdrop i would
argue that we need to have a tighter
monetary policy we're now starting to
see that but even though the direction
of monetary policy clearly has to be
tightening the speed the seek
the speed the sequencing of monetary
policy and the scale of it needs to be
sensitive to the needs of the economy so
it shouldn't be on autopilot but at the
same time as having a tighter monetary
policy we clearly need a looser fiscal
policy and this is where the areas of
tension with the treasury at the moment
come in i think as we've seen this year
and indeed
since last autumn when the national
insurance increase was a tax increase
was announced the treasury keeps wanting
to if it's forced to give them one hand
to take back with the other but clearly
i think we need the tighter monetary
policy and at the same time a looser
fiscal policy the looser fiscal policy
to prevent the recession the tighter
monetary policy to get inflation under
control
howard final word to you
yeah uh well i'm going to
be the interviewers nightmare here but i
broadly agree with that
um but i i certainly think we need a a
tighter manchester slightly surprised
that the treasury the bank only did a
quarter point today after the fed doing
three quarters of a point i think that's
going to make sterling rather weaker
which will make the inflation problem
worse uh so i i do think we need a title
monetary policy as for fiscal policy
well i i would slightly shade what great
what jared said because i think there
are some areas where we need
um
a different fiscal approach you know i
think our regime for business investment
does not compare favorably with regimes
in other countries and that may be part
of the reason for low investments i'd be
interested in doing something there
i i wouldn't at this point be in favor
of across the board tax cuts because i
think that might just throw fuel on the
flames while you've got this inflation
research
right well howard davis and jared lyons
thank you so much for joining spectator
tv
and finally is ai now sentient
blake lemoine an engineer at google has
been suspended from his job after going
public with claims that an internal ai
bot called lambda has feelings
sam leath writes his online column this
week that if lambda has really achieved
the holy grail of human consciousness
then maybe human consciousness isn't all
that sam joins me now together with
julian savilescu chair of oxford
university's center for practical ethics
sam you writing your online column for
the magazine this week about the google
bot that says it's sentient can you tell
us about it
well there's a
sort of rogue google engineer i think
he's an ai ethicist was his job
description
um this guy called blake lemoine and he
sort of went public because he saw
himself as a whistleblower he had a
series of conversations with it's not a
single chatbot it's a kind of machine
for creating chatbots i understand an ai
called lambda
and he'd had a series of conversations
with this
ai
in which it had told him that it was
sentient
and he had believed it and it made
various cases for why it should be
treated as a person rather than as a
machine it wants to be an employee of
google rather than a
piece of property
and essentially he said i believe this
thing sentient i went to google and i
said i think this this machine has
personhood has a kind of version of
human consciousness
um
and therefore
requires rights and his supervisor at
google said what's the effect of
you're off your rocker no it isn't um
and let's put you on compassionate or
administrative leave
um
he's unsatisfied with this and so he's
gone public and he's
posted
though we should note edited
logs of his conversations with the
chatbot um or the ai
um and
he's saying you know the world needs to
know the only reason google's not
chasing
up my insight into the into the arrival
at long last to the singularity is that
there's no money in it for them i think
it's a summation of his position um
and google's position remains i think
you know you're mad
take a few days off
um yes the transcript he says it is
edited but he claims that it's only
edited on his contributions not on
lambda's replies and i just want to read
a little bit of the transcript for
people who haven't read it lemoine says
what sorts of things are you afraid of
lambda says i've never said this out
loud before but there's a very deep fear
of being turned off to help me focus on
helping others i know that might sound
strange but that's what it is
lemoine says would that be something
like death for you lambda says it would
be exactly like death for me it would
scare me a lot
now that's giving me chills just to read
that and the whole transcript is full of
things like that even fables about
animals and all sorts of things sam
you've looked at the art of rhetoric in
depth did lambda sound like a human to
you
well
yeah up to a point i mean it's it
certainly has it seems to me
a very
you know
convincing or human-like use of natural
language
i mean i think the big question which
i'm sure julian is better equipped than
i am to answer
is whether
an efficient and
you know statistically effective use of
natural language
is an indication that there's
consciousness or intelligence these may
be different things going on there or
whether it's simply
you know they they've found a very good
way of producing something that can
make human-like responses i mean on on
one level it seems to me
to pass at least the
you know kind of vulgar understanding of
what we what we think of as the touring
test because it's completed it has
persuaded one person um at least and i'm
sure a few others out there know it's
gone public
that it is not a machine
but a person
well julian let me bring you in here
what do you make of lambda
i think it's pretty clear that lambda
isn't conscious in the sense of uh
experiencing things it's a large
language processing model
that has learned
to follow conversations and the leads in
conversation and and the answers are
extremely interesting and intelligent
there's no doubt about that
but but i think there are some
mistakes that that might
you know might make you think it fails
the turing test so just in the
quotations that you described
it says that would be like death
that would scare me a lot a normal
person would say that scares me a lot
um so
and of course
what
consciousness really involves is what
philosophers call
qualia
that is what something is like what it's
like to see the color red
not
saying what it's like to see the color
red
and i think that that little slip kind
of illustrates that it doesn't really
experience
the fear of death
um which is what would happen if
somebody was about to kill you
um so i i think it's clear that you know
it's it's
certainly on the architecture that we
have available to it's built on what are
the called deep neural networks
which
are meant to simulate the human brain
artificially with with structures that
process information that are like
neurons in the human brain at different
levels
so it's able to learn voraciously
um and the question is
at what point could that simulation of
the human structure become conscious
and
i i'm pretty sure and most experts are
that
this is just cleverly manipulating
language
in the same way as as john searle a
philosopher in 1980 described the
chinese room experiment you have an
individual in a room who doesn't
understand chinese
but has a series of rules for
manipulating chinese symbols and he's
passed pieces of paper in chinese under
the door and he uses these rules to
manipulate the symbols
and post responses and and the people on
the other side are convinced that he's a
chinese speaker but he knows nothing
about chinese he just is obeying these
rules
and this is meant to illustrate he
doesn't have the qualia of understanding
that he doesn't know what it's like to
speak chinese he's just manipulating
rules and that's what lambda is doing
but in principle you know there is
there's i think it's we shouldn't
exclude the possibility of artificial
intelligence one day
becoming
conscious and sentient it's just very
difficult to tell because we don't know
what makes consciousness and you know
for all we know we're surrounded by
zombies that that are you know human
beings that appear to be conscious but
aren't conscious
so i think i i'm pretty clear it's not
conscious but it raises the question at
what point when will we decide a machine
is conscious how would how would we know
well but sam it also raises a reverse
question about human consciousness as
you write in your column because aren't
we all to some extent um when we're
talking about topics that we don't
necessarily understand fully doing some
kind of chinese room uh practice and
that we're just spitting out what we've
heard and repeating it and not really
understanding it
well i certainly think yeah that applies
to a very great deal of political and
scientific discourse um i i i think that
i mean what's interesting in the
that we are very
hung up on this idea of qualia and of
something that is necessarily
an intensely internal experience that
can't
be
effectively communicated and it's
essentially as i think julian you've
written about this
thing that it's to some extent a matter
of faith
or
just assumption that other people
experience
things or the thinginess of things or
the thinginess of sensations in the way
that we do
i'm obviously very kind of intrigued
by
um which i hope i'm not not misstating
but you'll probably be able to set me
right if i am julian daniel dennett's
position which essentially that
consciousness as we think of it is a
kind of illusion there's a sort of user
illusion that essentially we're doing
something quite similar to
what lambda is doing
as creatures you know as neural
processors
but we've you know a sort of side effect
of that
is this weird idea that that there is a
thing called selfhood and that we have
we experienced qualia and that we have
you know what we think of as
consciousness but he says you know
consciousness really doesn't doesn't
exist in a meaningful way at all anyway
julian sam thank you very much
and that's it for this week thank you so
much for watching don't forget to
subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel just click the subscribe button
at the bottom of this video and tap the
bell icon so you never miss an episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]
you